doch wird ihnen präsentiert von 100
elektrischen nissan leaf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gut bevor wir zum eigentlichen thema
kommen und ihnen einige fragen stellen
möchten wir wissen weshalb sie schweizer
werden wollen
mit dem 6
dort scheint man setze ganz schwer für
mich weil die andere kammer vorliebe
position traffic bestaunen trieb
ich gebe meinen kollegen das wort wir
wussten dass es 13 personen sein werden
aber nicht was für fragen sie uns
stellen
es gibt bewerber die wissen nicht mehr
wie das viertel reisten dem sie wohnen
[Musik]
warum wollen sie schweizer werden
ein gebot wenn du vieles weist bist du
nie sicher ob du alle fragen beantworten
kannst gibt und sie boomen erklimmen
will und wir vergeben den schweizer pass
nicht leichtfertig clubs ist noch wie
viele es normal dass es so abläuft
das schweizer einbürgerungsverfahren ist
das strengste in ganz europa zwar gibt
es nur einen schweizer pass aber über
2000 wege ihn zu bekommen
das entspricht der anzahl gemeinden in
unserem land zum ersten mal haben
kommunale behörden in allen vier
sprachregionen zutritt zu ihren sehr
vertraulichen anhörungen gewährt bei dem
entscheidenden schritt vor der
kommission müssen die bewerberinnen und
bewerber ihres wissen es unter beweis
stellen und zeigen dass sie das
räderwerk dass unser land antreibt bis
ins kleinste detail kennen
willkommen in der einbürgerungs fabrik
bekommen bei fabrik die swisspor
schweizers la fabbrica dass vitali
schweizer machen
[Musik]
heute groß kampfstark vom ablauf einer
so machen wir machen zwei wölfe ist das
normal die bahn hinten gedenke alles
klar eigentlich lese ich bin register
pontresina und fallen da spontan auf
praxen hotel vom hotel team vom hotel
steiger kann nicht mit meiner haut sei
in dritter generation jetzt sind ich
denke das kann jede schweiz für gewährte
wo das will wo die welt betritt wo mit
einer werk verständigung leben und die
ist eine herzliche com arbeitet wilden
zeiten hinterher männer die mechanismen
das matratze kann verhinderte im sinn
[Musik]
es einen klassischen tourismusregion
sich zwölf nationen
ohne thomas walther wäre pontresina
nicht pontresina der hotelier ist
präsident der bürgergemeinde er sitzt in
etlichen verwaltungsräten
vor allem aber ist er einer der größten
arbeitgeber der äußerst touristischen
berggemeinde also ich mag im regen
dominierte hin praktisch alles um
schließlich italienische gastarbeiter
damals zeit hat kann den echten erich
spanien gegangen
denn ich sah richtig dass lage damals
gemeint ich als portugal sehr stark
praktisch alle hits höchsten das dass
der wohlstand schweiz hev schweiz
erarbeitet hat und wenig schweiz baut
autobahnen wenige schweizer baut also
die ganze wirtschaft ist so wild landes
spielt queen
das ganze hätte schönere arbeiten
das ist eigentlich das ziel das
strahlende jugendliche zum teil kinder
können die berichte für familien schon
jetzt sind rund 1000 sind viel
entspannter geboren
und deiner dem rhein klar wurzeln im
kleinen ferienorts mit 2000 einwohnern
kennt jeder jeden und wer sich
einbürgern lassen will kennt thomas
walther auch für familie corona cardoso
führt kein weg an ihm vorbei in ein paar
monaten wird er sie anhören
ist das wieder kohler
ich habe viel zu viel höchste gegessen
gegen vier oder fünf solltest du
vertrauen kann
[Musik]
genau das fehlt alles andere ist schon
gemacht
nach 30 jahren im engadin hat sich die
italienische portugiesische familie doch
noch dazu entschlossen sich einbürgern
zu lassen
anna und burlo sind bereit sich auf das
schier endlose verfahren einzulassen und
wenig mini lieblings dorf gut die stände
mahnte kennengelernt und und das bleibt
mir immer im herz nach 30 jahren in 3d
also das ist meine zweite heimat
[Musik]
und wenn du gesehen hast du so gut
integriert bist und du so freundlich und
das sind die schade dass du ohne die
schwester spaß kann schnitker abstimmen
spezielle kompliziert weil man produkt
bestimmte sachen sieht alich aus
portugal die tochter ist in der schweiz
geboren
organisation vom portugiesischen
konsulate in gruppen auf und nein wir
haben alles in mailand machen lassen
ein schriftstück fehlt immer noch
um an das dokument zu kommen setzt anna
auf eine bestens organisierte
gemeinschaft der konsul von portugal
kommt regelmäßig aus zürich bei dem
portugiesen im engadin vorbei er hat
sein mobiles büro mit dabei
das ist sehr sehr groß unterstützt wurde
portugiesische gemeinschaft hinter dem
ganz viel zeit und und eigentlich auch
späße spaß schweizer feldbach und
erleichtert der schweizer pass nicht
einfach nur das leben uns gibt er das
gefühl noch besser in die schweiz
integriert zu sagen ich fühle mich nicht
als schweizerin ich bin punkt tessinerin
[Musik]
ich brauchte einen geburtsschein und
unsere heiratsurkunde ich habe vor über
einem monat bei meiner heimatgemeinde
nachgefragt zum glück kann ich dort noch
ein paar leute sonst kann sich das in
die länge ziehen für paulo ist es nur
ein kurzer abstecher in sein heimatland
die gemeinde in der er aufgewachsen ist
liegt auf der anderen seite des bernina
passes in italien
dort hatte er auch mit einer gewohnt als
sie frisch zusammengezogen war damals
als grenzgänger haben sie täglich 120
kilometer zurückgelegt bei jedem wetter
im winter gab es immer viel verkehr und
viel schnee
nach einem langen arbeitstag die strecke
müde zurückzulegen um nach hause zu
kommen
das war
aber wir waren jung in diesen jahren
haben wir ziemlich viel auf uns kennen
nur für die arbeit
wir wollten wissen wie es ist in der
schweiz zu arbeiten
[Musik]
wie das wetter wechselt
ist schon fast frühling
[Musik]
für mich ist das für ihn eine andere
welt hier bin ich aufgewachsen in berlin
ist vieles besser organisiert als im
restlichen italien
hier sind deine urkunden
ich finde er ist seit 2000 bürgermeister
und schon habe ich etwas wichtiges
erreicht
nach so langer zeit in der schweiz haben
wir doch mehr verdient als nur die
arbeit oder
keller
[Musik]
ganz anders als in graubünden ist die
sichtweise im kanton tessin bei fast
70.000 grenzgängern täglich werden
ausländer anders wahrgenommen
[Musik]
ich heiße david münster ich stamme aus
eritrea
ich bin 46 jahre alten lebe seit fast
zwölf jahren in der schweiz
ich bin verkäufer im media markt
ich war im krieg gegen äthiopien die
tage für mein land gekämpft
dabei wurde ich verletzt ich habe mein
blut für eritrea gegeben
meine großeltern haben 30 jahre lang
gegen äthiopien gekämpft sie sind nicht
geflüchtet
auf meiner freunde führenden kampf
weiter ich nicht ich musste nach zehn
jahre militärdienst hat sich david dazu
durchgerungen aus eritrea zu flüchten wo
die kämpfe andauern
er musste seine ganze familie
zurücklassen als er sich für ein leben
im exil entschied
wenn du daran denkst aus eritrea zu
fliehen
rechnest du nicht damit dass der weg so
hart sein wird
am härtesten war die sahara und das mehl
der wüste ohne wasser hältst du keinen
halben tag
wenn du einen freund mein kind eine frau
in der wüste stärken siehst dann denkst
du daran umzugehen
aber du kannst nicht wer geht schon um
und wenn jemand auf dem meer im boot
stirbt dann nimmst du ihn nicht bis nach
italien mit sondern erst ihn über bord
wir fragen uns wie human die situation
ist
du machst die ganze reise durch libyen
mit einem jungen der unterwegs stirbt du
wirst ihn ins meer noch bevor du italien
erreicht hast was hat das für einen
segen sein körper ist zwar in italien
angekommen aber deine seele erholt sich
niemals
[Musik]
nach zweieinhalb jahren ungewissheit
erhielt david den flüchtlingsstatus und
beantragte den familiennachzug seine
frau und seine tochter konnten zu ihm
nach lugano reichen
seither sind noch zwei söhne dazu
gekommen heute besitzt er einen c
ausweis vor kurzem hat er für sich und
seine familie ein einbürgerungsgesuch
gestellt
[Musik]
für david bedeutete die schweiz genf und
die menschenrechte
doch als er in tessin ankam stand der
kanton unter dem einfluss der lega dei
ticinesi und deren sehr restriktive
einwanderungspolitik
david wird das hautnah zu spüren
bekommen
seit über 25 jahren sitzt einleger
mitglied der kommunalen
einbürgerungskommission vor politik ist
meine leidenschaft
die tessiner lega hat mir raum
geschaffen von der cvp hatte ich mich
enttäuscht abgewandt
zu der zeit waren meine eltern mit
giuliano bignasca befreundet und so kam
ich zur liga
[Musik]
im kanton tessin ist wahltag er näher
petrini ist unterwegs zu seinem
stammtisch um die ergebnisse zu erfahren
für mich hat diese kampagne zwei aspekte
zum einen die ergebnisse stadtrat und
und grossen rat diesen natürlich nicht
zum anderen erlebe ich die wahl aber
auch auf einer persönlicheren ebene weil
ich ja selbst für einen sitz im grossen
rat kann man weiß ich ob ich
wiedergewählt wurde länger für immer und
gewinnen morgen soll sie aufs titelblatt
die läger das war eine bewegung der
unzufriedenen und dehnt die klar ist es
einfacher die unzufriedenen zu bewegen
hat die zufrieden
inzwischen ist die lega überall
vertreten vom stadtrat in lugano bis in
den tessiner staatsrat auch auf allen
stufen de einbürgerungsverfahren trifft
man auf liga mitglieder die harten
positionen der partei in
einwanderungsfragen haben zu einer
verschärfung der kantonalen gesetze über
das bürgerrecht gefühlt die
anforderungen hier gehen weit über die
kriterien des bundesgesetzes hinaus
sollte es hier schwieriger sein als
anderswo schweizer zu werden
die lega ist nicht grundsätzlich gegen
die einbürgerung die lega ist aber
dagegen dass man leuten den schweizer
pass schenken die nicht verdienen petri
findet dass man sich den schweizer pass
verdienen müsse für david und seine
familie bedeutet das dass er sich am tag
ihrer anhörung vor dem
kommissionspräsidenten keine fehler
leisten dürfen
das einbürgerungsgesuch hat david vor
sechs monaten eingereicht
seither warte er auf das aufgebot wie es
das schloss in bellinzona
was du gestern dort das waren vielleicht
viele stufen wir wurden gefragt wie wir
aufräumen
der lehrer hat gefragt wollte den lift
nehmen oder zu fuß hoch wir alle den
lift darauf der lehrer gut dann gehen
alle zu fuß
wer also auf über die treppe darf nie
und ich war ganz vorne
das war der aufstieg zum everest oben
angekommen waren wir total erledigt wie
viele stufen war müssten sicher nicht
nur ein kilometer
vielleicht 100 200 meter nicht mehr
warum war die so müde kinder ihr seid
jung als ich so alt war wie ihr habe
jeden tag 16 kilometer zurückgelegt zu
fuß ja um in die schule zu gehen
ich habe ich das schon mal erzählt acht
kilometer hin und 8 kilometer zurück und
du behauptest nach fünf minuten
treppensteigen seist du erledigt skala
die heutige jugend
ich habe den kindern auch gesagt was es
für mich bedeutet eingebürgert zu werden
das ist mir wichtig ich fühle mich hier
zu haben sein ich arbeite hier meine
kinder sind hier geboren mein ganzes
leben spielt sich hier ab
deshalb habe ich den antrag gemacht
st
[Musik]
aber das kann man nach europa fahren die
leute haben die nette angewohnheit gern
auf diese schöne ecken kupplung wo viel
spannung viel strom stärker fließt oft
pinkeln
sollte man mich meinen aber tatsächlich
so groß nicht machen
zu gefährlich nicht ganz die feine
schweizer art aber es bräuchte mehr um
andreas davon abzubringen schweizer
werden zu wollen
andreas luthe stammt aus der ehemaligen
ddr irgendwo ein traum bundesrepublik
interessiert mich nicht
mein land gibt es nicht mehr die gr und
da ist für mich die schweiz wo ich mich
heimisch viele und dann ist natürlich
dann die logische konsequenz dass man
eben auch staatsbürger versucht zu sagen
also beantragt und versucht zu erreichen
[Musik]
andreas und seine familie ließen sich
vor 13 jahren am ufer des zürichsees
nieder
wenn man so will auf der falschen seite
sie konnten ja nicht wissen dass
freienbach zum eher konservativen kanton
schwyz gehört der mit am
zurückhaltendsten einbürgert so wie ich
gehört habe dass im kanton schwyz mit am
schlimmsten
man hat ja auch arbeitskollegen die
hinter sich hatten aber eben in zürich
und welche zur anhören
sie ist eine person
man springt immer so kleinen städtchen
in der höhe und in freienbach springt
man nicht mehr drei meter hohe mauer
andreas weiß wovon er redet
seine tochter ist gegen die mauer
gerannt sie war vor fünf jahren die
erste der familie die sich einbürgern
lassen wollte ihre anhörung erlebte sie
wie einen albtraum
da war sie gerade 20 jahre alt
natürlich ganz klar
[Musik]
wenn man ja tochter als nicht geklappt
ich finde sie traurig dass es nicht
geklappt hat aber das ist nicht so dass
mich das ermutigt sie hätte er weiter
versuchen können aber es wird die
konsequenz sitzung ist wieder nach
deutschland zurück tochter lisa hatte
ihre jugendzeit in freienbach verbracht
die abschlägige antwort empfand sie als
komplette ablehnung
daraufhin kehrte sie der schweiz den
rücken zurück blieb andreas mit seinem
wunsch weiter zu werden
den sieben monaten wird er vor demselben
gremium stehen dass seine tochter
abgewiesen hat daher die kennt
[Musik]
annina herrmann war bei lisas anhörung
mit dabei zu den gründen weshalb lisa
gescheitert ist will sie nicht sagen
sie verweist auf die bestimmungen halten
[Musik]
ging wohlhabenden freienbach stand ein
drittel der einwohnerschaft aus dem
ausland an nina hermann wohnt seit über
30 jahren hier
die pensionierte pflegefachfrau macht
beim generationenübergreifenden projekt
senioren in der kinderkrippe mit
[Musik]
erfolgreiche integration denkmal
abhängig von der sprache bis acht
verschiedene nationalitäten kam und wo
ich brauch zum beispiel behaupten könnte
einige dieser kinder sollten sie sich
eines tages einbürgern lassen wollen
finden sich vielleicht dereinst vor nina
hermann wieder
das gesetz sieht die möglichkeit vor
dass minderjährige ab 12 jahren alleine
angehört werden können
so beginne mit geographie geschichte
sprache war drews der kurs und da gibt
so grundwissen in der vorbereitung für
einbürgerungswillige ist andreas an
seinem sechsten und letzten kurs wie die
anderen bewerbenden bereitet er sich auf
den kantonalen einbürgerungstest vor in
freienbach ist das bestehen des tests
voraussetzung für die aufnahme des
verfahrens und soll kantone galaxie
da können sie sie bedacht schon auf
zellen wieder abkürzung sg steht für tvs
ist ca
gibt's nicht durch welche sehen fließt
der rhein
sie haben eine grosse schweizer karte
man muss eben viel zu sagen dass ein
gegenseitiges nehmen und geben
und dafür muss man ein wort bringen
einfach so schwer wie zugeworfen also
müsste man dann wahrscheinlich nicht so
zu schätzen als wenn man es selber
geschafft hat wenn vertreten die
nationalräte nationale binnen die
bevölkerung also bevölkerungsreiche
kantone haben viele vertreterinnen
bevölkerungsarmen kantone aber eher
weniger die stellen direkte vertreten
also ich finde es sehr gut dass man eben
sich auch über das land informiert über
die bildung über die kultur was jetzt
nun jeder schweizer
in der schule lernt dass man da auch
bescheid weiß
spüren sie jetzt noch teile sozial
eigentlich nicht ist bloß irgendwie hat
man wird fremdbestimmt man hat kein
eigenes ja ja wir können wohnungen
kaufen wir können alles machen wir
können nicht sagen welche politischen
kann ihn im parlament sein so das gefühl
dass man jetzt auch abstimmen dürfen
vielleicht für viele zum ersten mal im
leben ein kreuzchen machen im direkt
demokratischen system und zu sagen gut
wir sind jetzt teil noch dieser menge
dass eine gefühlssache und trotzdem geht
es eilig und viel gefühl vom herzen
willkommen bei der einbürgerung stelle
die von der stadt zusammen betrieben
wird
das angebot ist für einwohnerinnen und
einwohner die sich in deutschland
einbürgern lassen wollen kosten in
lausanne wird kein schriftlicher test
durchgeführt entscheidend ist die
anhörung vor der gemeinde alle hier in
diesem saal haben ihr gesuch vor der
anpassung des bundesgesetzes über das
schweizer bürgerrecht 2018 eingereicht
seither wurde das gesetz verschärft wer
den schweizer pass will braucht
mindestens einen c ausweis zehn jahre
aufenthalt im land schriftliche und
mündliche sprachkenntnisse und darf
während dreier jahre vor der gesuch
einreichen keine sozialhilfe bezogen
haben viele würden diese neuen
bedingungen nicht erfüllen
um ein scheitern zu vermeiden setzen die
bewerberinnen und bewerber auf das
ausbildner ehepaar brigid und des
konzerns
sie gehören zum maßnahmenpaket das für
die kandidierenden geschnürt wurde damit
sie bestehen
für uns ist es teil unserer
bürgerpflicht bricht und das
venezolanische doppelbürger haben selbst
das einbürgerungsverfahren durchlaufen
nachdem sie sich in loser niedergelassen
hatten
haben sie sich aktiv um ihre integration
bemüht um künftige mitbürger zu
unterstützen setzen sie all ihre energie
für das coachen 1
hallo die anhörung vor der
einbürgerungskommission ablaufen
ihnen werden fragen zum politischen
system der schweiz gestellt zur
geografie und zur geschichte
wer weiß wo sich das bundesamt für
gesundheit befindet es hat alle
denkbaren profile von der analphabeten
die als haushälterin arbeitet zum doktor
in philosophie der an der eth lausanne
unterrichtet die palette ist riesen die
gemeinde bildet den kern also sind sie
für oder gegen das bundesgesetz über die
steuerreform und die ahv finanzierung
menschen die den ganzen tag arbeiten und
um 6 müde nach hause kommen
man sieht es ihnen an das ist alles so
kompliziert und doch wissen sie es
wissen
wir sagen wir wissen zwar nicht genau
welche fragen man ihnen stellen wird
aber wir versuchen sie so gut wie
möglich vorzubereiten damit sie auf jede
frage eine antwort haben
wie heißt die präsidentin des
waadtländer staatsrat wer vertritt die
exekutive im kanton waadt wie viele
sätze hat er sieben können sie aufzählen
sowohl avelon bevor sie ihr gesuch
eingereicht haben
hat man diesen menschen gesagt dass die
politik nichts für sie sei weil sie
ausländer sind jetzt plötzlich müssen
sie das fehlende wissen nach offenbaren
wo haben die ersten eidgenossen ihren
schwur abgelegt
ich hab's fand gelesen
auf der rütliwiese genau
das ist schwierig der mann der mit der
armbrust einen pfeil durch einen apfel
geschossen hat der auf dem kopf seines
sohnes sagt nein nicht napoleon der
franzose in welcher stadt befindet sich
der berg haben
herzlichen glückwunsch mit nach mir
ginge mir bekämen sie alle den schweizer
pass
wenn die sein
die leute haben angst seit 40 jahren
haben sie keine schulbank mehr gedrückt
und dann sollen sie plötzlich eine
prüfung bestehen
schon allein die tatsache dass sie vor
einer kommission stehen versetzt sie in
angst und schrecken
[Musik]
vieles weiß ich ja schon trotzdem bin
ich etwas angespannt tina turner ist
schweiz
okay sie ist amerikanerin
sie ist vor millionen von menschen
aufgetreten aber trotzdem hatte sie nie
zuvor so viel angst im leben wie an dem
tag an dem sie für die einbürgerung
angehört wurde
[Musik]
bist du nervös wenn alles gut geht
sollte das keine große sache werden
was denkt wir werden sehen
gehen wir meine liebe sitzt man hemd
hinten richtig
ja ja
ich habe mich für den sitz in der
einbürgerungskommission beworben weil
ich den kontakt mit menschen schätze
menschen kennen lernen und mit ihnen
diskutieren das gefällt mir
ich weiß noch als ich in die schweiz
kamen fand ich die waadtländer sehr
ernst ich fand es am anfang schwierig
mit den los anderen in kontakt zu kommen
die leute hier sind etwas
zurückhaltender wenn die reserve
[Musik]
ich bin doppelbürgerin französin und
schweiß
ich habe in dieser studiert und dann
einen speicher kennengelernt
wir haben geheiratet und ich bin nach
lausanne gezogen ist das war 1973
damals war das gesetz anders wenn eine
frau einen schweizer heiratete wurde sie
automatisch weiteren der schweizer pass
war also gewissermaßen teil der mitgift
[Applaus]
diesen menschen muss man mit einer
gewissen seriosität begegnen ihnen
gegenüber angemessen auftreten
mir ist natürlich bewusst dass es für
sie um viel geht
hier entscheidet sich alles können wir
meine damen und herren
obwohl das italienische spanische
rentner paar schon seit gut 60 jahren in
der schweiz lebt fällt der entscheid
über seine einbürgerung hier vor dieser
kommission in nur 20 minuten
wir von der einbürgerungskommission
heißen sie willkommen bevor wir zum
eigentlichen thema kommen wollen wir
wissen weshalb sie sich einbürgern
lassen wollen
um mich als echter schweizer bürger zu
fühlen weil wir seit 60 jahren immer
etwas abseits stehen
bei den abstimmungen und auch sonst
unsere kinder sind schweizer unsere
enkelkinder auch warum sollten nicht
auch wir uns einbürgern lassen
ich lebe seit meinem achten lebensjahr
in der schweiz und ich habe mein leben
lang gearbeitet
ja sie haben immer gearbeitet ich habe
immer gearbeitet auch als die kinder
klein waren wir sehr gut dann fangen wir
mit den fragen an
wir gehen wir mit geschichte
einverstanden sagt ihnen der name maria
will etwas
er hat versucht eine revolution gegen
die berner anzuzetteln
er wurde geköpft aber der kanton waadt
ist ja dann doch unabhängig geworden in
welchem jahr 1788 98 genau 98
entschuldigung am 24 januar 17 98 nun
zur schweizer geschichte
es gibt eine erste bundesverfassung
wissen sie von wannen diese erste
bundesverfassung stammt das war 1874 das
war die zweite und die erste 1848 seien
garanten genau 1848 das war die erste
ich glaube nicht dass alle schweizer das
gesunde aber wir verlangen von den
ausländern die sich dieser prüfung
stellen dass sie das wissen das ist
ziemlich anspruchsvoll
ich liebe meinen kollegen das wort für
die weiteren themen
ich schlage vor dass wir mit den
politischen institutionen weitermachen
minuten werden zur ewigkeit die angst
vor dem entscheidenden fehler ist
jederzeit spürbar
auf stufe bundesversammlung besteht das
parlament aus wie vielen treffern
aus zwei kammern und wie heißen diese
beiden kammern der staatsrat wetter der
ständige ja der ständerat hat 46 sitze
bevor ich mitglied der
einbürgerungskommission wurde wusste ich
nicht wie viele nationalräte oder stehen
die räte es gibt ich hatte keine ahnung
willich den test hätte machen müssen ich
wäre durchgefallen muss ganz sicher
worin besteht der unterschied zwischen
einem referendum oder initiative wir
beginnt mit einem referendum stößt man
ein gesetz an
und dann ich habe gehört wie ihre frau
nein gesagt bitte korrigieren sie und
dann komme ich wieder zu ihnen zurück
also bitte das referendum man ergreift
ein referendum um gegen ein
beschlossenes gesetz vorzugehen sie noch
mal finde es normal dass dieses wissen
verlangt wird nicht normal ist dass die
meisten schweizer all das nicht wissen
welche verhalten hat das wappen von
lausanne weiß und rot das vom kanton
waadt weiß und grün
das ist richtig damit wäre das gespräch
zu ende wir zwei beraten uns jetzt
unfällen unseren entscheid den sie dann
von der gemeinde erhalten
bei einem positiven entscheid geht ihr
dossier an den kanton und dann weiter an
den bund sie brauchen etwas geduld denn
es dauert dann noch eineinhalb jahre
sie den schweizer pass erhalten vielen
dank
anderthalb jahre im besten fall denn das
bundesgesetz setzt keine fristen
es gibt nur empfehlungen ab
die stadt lausanne verpflichtet sich
immerhin den entscheid bis sechs wochen
nach der anhörung bekannt zu geben
es ist ganz gut gelaufen der entscheid
liegt doch bei ihnen nicht ja noch ist
nichts entschieden aber ich glaube wir
haben uns gut geschlagen
die einbürgerungskommission von lausanne
hat uns die einmalige gelegenheit
gegeben mit der kamera an ihrer beratung
dabei zu sein
wir gehen jetzt die einzelnen punkte
durch beherrschung der französischen
sprache spricht sehr gut französisch wer
hat unsere fragen perfekt verstanden und
uns korrekt gar antwort sehr gut und sie
doch auch integration integration gut
man merkt dass er mein los angelegt
haben
sie besitzen in eigentumswohnungen haben
zwei erwachsene kinder die virtuos
akkorde und spielen eine echte
erfolgsgeschichte
dann schreiben wir perfekt integriert
effekte fiel bei beiden einverstanden
kenntnisse der geschichte weil ihr
ausgezeichnet bei ihm etwas weniger
sagen wir sehr gut da der anspannung
konnte er wahrscheinlich nicht all seine
fähigkeiten kenntnisse einbringen
wir können sehr gut sitzen dann sind wir
uns eigentlich sehr gut der vorentscheid
fällt damit positiv aus exportiert
eliane aubert und ihr kollege gehen zum
nächsten dass hier über die zeit drängt
bis ende des jahres muss die kommission
zwingend alle 1600 bewerbungsdossier
saab arbeiten die noch unter dem alten
gesetz eingereicht wurden um dieses ziel
zu erreichen arbeitet die zehnköpfige
kommission in zweier teams die sich
täglich abwechseln die ausländerinnen
und ausländer in lausanne haben ein
schreiben der stadtverwaltung bekommen
in dem erklärt wurde dass es eine neue
strengere einbürgerungs gesetzgebung
gebe wir haben ihnen damals empfohlen
das gesuch vor dem 31
dezember 2017 einzureichen damit das
dossier gemäß dem alten gesetz behandelt
wird was die einbürgerung erleichtert
sie schreibt über sie
bevor sie von der
einbürgerungskommission angehört werden
müssen die bewerber aber erst eine
andere hürde nehmen
anna und burlo haben nun endlich alle
dokumente beisammen wie sie für das
verfahren benötigen
nach all den jahren habe ich jetzt alle
unterlagen die ich brauche er will kunde
sieg
16 die ganze unterlag show vorbereitet
und dem man ganz schlechte nachricht
über co dass der baum und ranke dann ist
ganz klar ich sind alle dokument
abgelaufen
denn ich muss alles die grafen von euch
gute kopie in der ganzen schweiz ist es
dasselbe geduldspiel bis der papierkram
erledigt ist und alle benötigten
unterlagen vorliegen
niederlassungsbewilligung
identitätsausweis strafregisterauszug
sprachnachweis leumundszeugnis
betreibungsregister auszug lohn ausweise
personenstandsregister auszug
steuererklärung referenzen und meist
auch noch ein bewerbungsschreiben
das ist nicht nichts ja wie viele
aber jetzt habe ich sie alle beisammen
überall in der schweiz sieht die
einbürgerungspraxis etwas anders aus im
tessin muss man einen test bestehen den
mann nach einem obligatorischen 40
stündigen kurs ablegen kann
in schwyz steht es den gemeinden frei
einen kantonalen test zu verlangen die
bewerben dann müssen aber eine
selbsteinschätzung zu ihrer integration
ausfüllen
es ist ein kommen habe keine sozialhilfe
bezogen und habt ihr ein verbrechen
begangen energien oder eine übertretung
busek mehr als 1000 franken gekostet hat
während andreas kopf schütteln das
formular ausfüllt brauchen corona cadooz
in pontresina jedoch sie nur noch zur
post zu bringen damit das verfahren
seinen lauf nicht schnell gehen werden
alles passen
abwarten für david hat die dauer des
verfahrens folgen als flüchtling kann er
nicht nach eritrea zurück seine kinder
haben weder ihre heimat nach ihrer
verwandten dort je gesehen seit 13
jahren sehnt sich david nach einem
wiedersehen mit seinem fach ohne pass
ist daran nicht zu denken
wie gehts es geht habe ich werde langsam
alt das sagst du schon lange hält david
mainzer immerhin bin ich jetzt 85 gut
die kinder sind hier bei mir ich gebe
dir mias wie geht es dir
mir geht es gut kleiner aber ihr fehlt
mir sehr
heute ist ein gesegneter tag es ist ein
gesegneter sonntag
das ist gut man soll mein einziger
wunsch ist dich wieder zu sehen bevor es
zu spät ist ausgeschlossen dass du uns
verlässt du wirst 90 jahre alt das
wichtigste ist dass ich dich wiedersehen
ich wünsche mir nur dass namen papa
länger auf das gespräch wird sonst zu
teuer
ich ruf dich bald wieder an
einverstanden so in ordnung
mein vater ist 85 jahre alt er kann
nicht in die schweiz reisen und ich kann
nicht zurück nach eritrea riet er
das betrifft nicht nur mich sondern alle
die in der schweiz asyl beantragt haben
die die nach schweden oder norwegen noch
finnland oder in die niederlande gehen
oder nach großbritannien
wir haben noch fünf oder sechs jahren
ein pass und können nach eritrea zurück
deshalb fragt mich mein vater immer
wieder
damit warum kommst du nicht ihn umarmen
zu können fehlt mir sein lachen zu sehen
mir ist das sehr wichtig dass es
passieren wird aber ich hoffe dass er
nicht jetzt geht nicht bevor ihn besucht
haben
es kommt mir so wie beim eislaufen oder
wir haben jetzt die pflicht module die
haben wir jetzt gehabt und am dienstag
konnten ihre kühe wie steht es um ihr
impuls im moment etwa von 0 bis 10 10
wäre ganz so wo ist so relaxt den job
ziemlich ziemlich hoch was macht das
angst aus der puste hochrhein
ich glaube die wichtigkeit wenn diese
prüfung für uns alle gut nervös ja man
hofft das beste und wir haben montag
frei da kann man drei tage intensiv das
nutzen
bis das schaffen wir alle
alles gute und viel erfolg
andreas stellt sich den 50 fragen des
einbürgerungstests des kantons schwyz
scheiterte er wird das gesamte verfahren
eingestellt
davids hat einen befristeten
arbeitsvertrag
er hofft bald einen unbefristeten von
seinem arbeitgeber zu bekommen denn
sonst erfüllt er eine voraussetzung für
die einbürgerung nicht jeder bewerber
muss für sich und seine familie
aufkommen können während anna und paulo
ihrer arbeit nachgehen prüfen die
bündner behörden er dossier auf herz und
nieren beim kleinsten makel geht es an
die absender zurück und das spiel
beginnt von vorn in lusan folgt eine
anhörung auf die andere ohne pause
gerade ist das bier passiva nissan aus
sri lanka an der reihe sich den fragen
der einbürgerungskommission zu stellen
[Musik]
dort wurde ihnen präsentiert von 100
elektrischen nissan leaf